my name is superintendent roberta mchale
with the royal canadian mounted police
in alberta i'm here to speak to you
today with regards to our incidents in
the last 24 hours leading to several
arrests
pertaining to the illegal protests
that's been taking place here in coots
as well as 18 kilometers north
by milk river
last night
we had a
vehicle that
we had checkpoints and uh one particular
checkpoint
uh tractor tr from a farm implement a
very large with the
a scoop in the front
uh came at one of our members in the
vehicle and they had to avoid him and
then ended up with a
tractor-trailer semi that was involved
in a coordinated effort and it was in an
attempt to
push or ram our
police vehicle
from there
the occupants of the two vehicles ran
and ended up going into an area where
the protesters were located
we were able to identify one of the
males that were driving one of the
vehicles and our investigation is
continuing we know who that person is
and we will release information upon
that person's arrest
our members have been up here and in
general
we haven't had many incidents involving
violence but unfortunately an
investigation started
after a period of time when the initial
protesters arrived
shortly thereafter we began to receive
imminent information of potential
threats
it took some time to investigate that
and to determine facts which have led us
to several arrests
during the night last night
these arrests and this investigation is
continuing we have since made another
arrest involving this
the escalation of violence towards the
members
including having someone break
one of our checkpoints this afternoon
and just about hit one of our members on
the road
so we certainly have concerns about how
this has developed and our investigation
into what could be a number of different
charges and a number of different acts
has created a situation where we're
investigating conspiracy to attempt to
commit murder
and then we have other investigations
involving
the firearms clearly
so a search warrant was conducted
last night in the air by it was
approximately midnight 12 30
where three trailers associated to a
group that had
arrived
separate to the original
protesters but in
ended up being a part of this whole
situation
and this group we conducted a search
warrant into three trailers associated
to them resulting in the seizure of
weapons firearms ammunition
as well as
body worn armor that would normally be a
police issue
and
these people were taken into custody
we have determined that the
investigation is ongoing and we will
continue to investigate this
for the safety of the public
and for the safety of the police
it's important for us to say that our
message has always been to have
the public safe and the police safe and
as more and more information came to
light
it was important for us to have people
leave the illegal blockade we encourage
people to leave
and
unfortunately we were able to with the
province of alberta secure an area for
people to move to to peacefully protest
that were
interested in continuing to protest and
at this point we hadn't had a lot of
people go there they wanted to remain at
the location both here at milk river and
coats
and
we ended up
having to act on our information due to
the totality of the situation and
obviously the increased danger to our
police and ultimately if the police are
at a risk
the public is at a risk because we need
to protect the public and we can't have
our situation be where
we don't have the ability to defend
ourselves and then on top of that defend
the public
the threats
were
taken the time was taken to investigate
them to get to this point
and it is our investigation is
continuing this isn't uh this isn't over
at this point we have to continue to
look into things
we have asked for people to leave and
continue to ask for people to leave we
continue to ask for people to stay away
because we couldn't guarantee
at one point where things were going to
go with regards to the safety of the
members and as soon as it escalates the
point that a decision had to be made we
acted and like i said this was a very
complex
layered investigation
and some people might ask why it took so
long
these investigations aren't necessarily
easy we have a team of people that are
dedicated to investigate them and it
took to the point where we knew what was
about to happen or in inevitably to
happen and we acted as soon as we could
any questions the trailers they were
here in coats they were in milk river
when did they arrive and if they were in
coats how did they get here because
there were police checkpoints yeah i
don't know when they arrived they were
here in kutz
can you take me through the volatility
that is seemingly escalated in the last
little bit here and how members of the
ground are feeling
well
all of us are dedicated to serving the
province of alberta and our citizens and
it's troubling if
you have people that are here to cause
harm to our own members and we just want
everyone to be safe and that was our
entire
effort here
we wanted people to move away from the
illegal blockade because of safety
issues and we wanted to have this
resolved where people could safely use
the highway and the border to get across
to do their business
and to do their personal work and that
was blockaded
and then to have people coming as well
like with heavy equipment and you guys
have probably heard that
three large pieces of equipment were
i guess it stopped from being able to be
used and that was because
our investigation led us that those
pieces of equipment were coming here
and we told them not to come here
and we asked them to leave and then the
risk is is that if we can't have more
heavy equipment coming here for a
fortification
and they needed to go and they didn't so
part of our situation is protecting the
public but also not allowing it to go
beyond that the trucks were upon the
weapons were they located in the on the
road in the blockade or elsewhere in
coupes
so we've had different arrests they were
the majority of the weapons that we
located were in the three trailers and
then earlier today we had an arrest on
the highway where two
two firearms were seized and a person
was arrested as well so that's the 12th
arrest but the trucks that you
discovered the representative were they
in the blockade on the road or were they
off located in in a field or in
autonomous village no one of them was on
the highway coming here and due to
imminent threat we located that vehicle
and arrested that person and then we had
three trailers and i say trailers in as
in not a truck or a tractor but three
trailers that were here where a stash of
weapons was located including
firearms long barrel weapons and uh you
have the list in town but or on the
highway in town here associated down the
road here is the um conspiracy to commit
murder charges that in the
the incident in the trailers and that
vehicle with all the that's correct
okay and can you tell me what the status
of those
uh people who are charged are they in
custody
what's going on with them yeah we have
people in custody and they have a court
process that takes place where i don't
believe any of them have had an
information sworn where they would be
charged as of yet and once that happens
we'll do another release to
update you all on that and including the
charges that were
uh that are considered so i spoke to one
of the protest organizers uh before you
put your release out i have to be
transparent about that
and
the account that i got was very
different than what what the rcmp is
saying um
one that the
the truck and the trailer that were
involved in the incident
that they were just basically warming
their batteries up and driving around
is that
uh is there a possibility that that was
what happened
there the investigation that led to that
that situation is not them warming up
their vehicles and
just moving around they came at our
member in a vehicle that was parked on
the road doing a block and that member
had to move to avoid being pushed by
this huge piece of equipment
and then the other
vehicle that was utilized was involved
as well it was in my opinion coordinated
and that will be resolved at court
protest organizers in ottawa have
already
said that
the police
here are essentially lying that this is
not true
there are certainly a number of people
in the protests here that have that
belief as well how do you convince them
that what you're saying is true
the truth is is that this absolutely
took place and i'm not going to argue
with somebody who isn't going to listen
to the facts
i have no intention of doing that
there are people with all sorts of
opinions but the truth is is that
there's a heavy stash of weapons and
these weapons were brought by people who
had the intent on causing harm and
there are also people here who are here
to protest and they
very likely didn't know what was going
on here
but that is not up to me to decide as to
what level things are at and you can
you can imagine our situation and some
people have asked for pictures and i'm
sure they will come but people have to
accept the truth and understand our
situation is to protect the public and
in order to do that we act on facts
do you think you got them all
the investigation continues and if
there's more to be found we'll find them
that doesn't really answer that question
though do you think you got them all and
are you worried
i i don't know i'm not the investigator
i certainly hope that uh if there is a
situation where there's someone else
involved that uh
arrests happen
so for clarity the investigation into
the the charge of conspiracy to attempt
murder that the intended target was an
rcmp officer
yeah i don't know the fine details of
the investigation i just know that a
threat was against our member our
members in general and that
as you saw in the brief that we had
docked on that information
in your release you refer to it as
organized crime what do you mean by that
what sort of organization are we talking
about
i think that the investigation will
reveal the in-depthness of that i don't
know the exact uh
characterization that it would be to
lead this but there's certainly a group
that came in after the initial group
arrived
within days and then
this action began and it came to a point
where
for the safety of the members and for
the safety of the public we certainly
had to act and
enact quickly you say that this group
was
sort of embedded in the larger group is
that a fair assessment of it
yes we had uh
and we had also the difficulty of having
two locations of unlawful protest
separated by 18 kilometers so we had two
different groups of people
and i don't know how in depth
their involvement is i don't know
how many numbers of people were involved
in this but that's up to the
investigators to ensure that it
continues to be investigated so is there
a possibility that this group
that you arrested were acting completely
in their own silo and without others in
the protest knowing about them i don't
know uh that's going to come out through
evidence at court i'm sure okay
i know you did just want to speak to the
events that have unfolded but can you
give any update on what's next from
police on the rcmp
what's next is we're going to ensure
that this border is opened and stays
open safely and
that the public is able to use the
highways and use the border as it's
meant to be
and certainly
our opinion is is that
any sort of protest that continues uh
after this point
the government of alberta has provided
us equipment that we're going to use to
remove people
and
it as i've said all along
the best way to get the
the vehicles off the road is to have
people take them off themselves and
drive away and if we have to come back
and charge people we will
any timeline on that
well i the border needs to open so it's
an it's very important and we already
have people i've been advised pulling
out and leaving
and uh
i guess we'll see how long that takes
our goal is uh has always remained that
we understand and everyone does that
canadians uh have the right to peaceful
protest
in a lawful location and in a lawful pro
process and clearly that didn't happen
here and we acted on that
as i mentioned the problem says
or at least is going to supply the
vehicles or
machinery that's necessary to clear
these roadblocks is that machinery here
now
uh it's it's
coming today
if not already here so 11 people
arrested at the time of the release one
more twelfth person since then and then
uh what about the driver of the tractor
is he has he or she been we're working
on that i don't know where that stands
okay yeah
yeah
it's a big piece of farm equipment to
have coming at you
are you making any special efforts to
document the work of the officers field
document the work of this this is a big
investigation and we're documenting
things yes what percentage of the
officers are wearing body cams
uh i don't have that information
and then sorry the driver of the
semi-trailer have they been identified
have they been arrested
um
oh the semi truck that's
i don't have that information i know
that they were able to id for sure one
person and the investigation continues
are all the people arrested canadian
citizens i don't have that information i
i can't comment on that